I hadn't even asked what do you say
Pinocchio amazing that's a great
suggestion to start us off I like that
thank you for Pinocchio let's kind of
come to this wedge here pickleball oh do
you a fan it's dope
I love you cool if you never play
pickleball
it's like tennis but way back you should
have to run as far pickleball and
Pinocchio you just demonstrating your
range of motion on your wrist there and
you were like and I can do forehand and
that can just showing off just like yeah
that's good that's exciting
pickleball Pinocchio let's get a word
from you guys but once that you said
rugby and you said lesbians wait what
was it you said you said rugby okay do
you mind if I combine that and do
lesbian rugby amazing Pinocchio
pickleball lesbian rugby I mean I find
rugby very tedious I'd watch it if it
was that that's let's get a word from
you guys miss do you see mischievious
that's very fun because i who pronounces
it mischievous yeah I pronounce it
mischievous who pronounces it
mischievious you're so well-behaved just
hands up yeah that's that's why I can't
be a rapper yeah we've got any ladies in
the house yes yes hello I'm here
mischievious mischievious lesbian rugby
pickleball Pinocchio back at the room
what you gonna hit us with kangaroos and
animals so is forbidden I'm afraid but
you sound Australian so welcome what do
you say Walmart Oh topical topical
topical fun fun fun okay those are the
suggestions we have mischievious Walmart
lesbian rugby pickable and Pinocchio a
Utah are you telling her that I'm good
is that what you were just doing that
was really sweet of you you like have
you seen him before and she's like no
he's like it's actually really good it's
not because the whole thing is you think
it's gonna be [ __ ] but then
that's why I rely on I need I need
people to think it's bad and then let's
fries I like you a phone case by the way
man the chef on this that's a love look
at that that's like that's really cool
it's also the most narcissistic thing
I've ever seen just it's got a selfie
camera and then a mirror on the back
just I didn't tell them the wart your
wallpaper was you don't worry uh-huh
it's not it's not it's a beautiful photo
of the see I've really upset you know it
was so sweet he was like this guy's
great you're gonna love him rah I mean I
don't like him even if he is good I'm
upset
so mischievious lesbian rugby Pinocchio
pickleball and warmer they will all be
combined together to form an amazing and
astounding an astonishing freestyle rap
made up entirely on the spot never to be
repeated never performed before and it's
gonna be astounding if we could drop
that be good sir let's show him how we
do and you can give a little bit of
volume on that as well yeah kick you off
with bluster I like to be mischievious I
discussed there why do you add an extra
syllable mischievous is more fun yeah
keep it simple
miss Chiefy is like I'm the chief are
playing around go you finger in the air
put it out when I made the sounds flow
from my mouth I like to meddle have fun
let me wander to a store with a big gun
yeah I've got my hand on my heart my
Second Amendment test this in warmer
that guy literally did this today he is
crazy here in the USA he's like yeah I
stand by my rights it's vital I'm
walking in with the vest and a rifle and
obviously everyone was like no out of
the Walmart store you must go he was
like I'm just having a laugh everyone is
like really don't do that no one would
like what the [ __ ] there you got your
finger in there
like a conductor it doesn't make sense
yeah
moving it round let me move on now one
thing I have found sports a damn boring
but if you made lesbians play them I
would watch every day I'll be like yeah
this the best of all I like rugby look
how they handle those balls literally
they just leave them on the field I'm
not touching that no I yield I don't
want it there I'm no full stay away
rugby ball strange shape oval why are
the post like a giant H great game for
lesbians to play and other people
obviously what am I like don't wanna
star a stereotype in and move on yeah
wool worn by a fire what's it made a
tiny little boy liar all the words that
I'm used in as fuel is made by Pinocchio
he thought he was cool he was like oh
I've got a high voice I say so I want to
be a real boy please do better who are
creepy old guy whittling away
I want a little son I'll make one today
I'll break all the pieces off of this
stool Geppetto stay 50 feet from this
school you know you're not allowed a
real kid
it's disgusting why are you feeling it
no I'm painting him with a little yellow
hat you dick it was this thing that's
Jiminy Cricket
shut up that's just a locust on his
shoulder the Blue Fairy all made him
older Steven Spielberg referenced it
what a guy it's the ending of the film
ai you'd be stacking up the glasses I
keep coming back to you
the last thing remind me what the hell
we need to do what was the last one
can we go oh yeah if you're far too old
to run across a call if your needs her
you need to get a pickleball yarra do
tour everybody you start serving but you
stand behind the line I believe I'm
getting all the roars quite fine it's
played of half of a tennis court really
fun to to everyone go sign up I'll come
with you
cuz I'm very fun fit cardiovascularly as
you can see I'm swell when I spin these
our pickleball but not in a jar that's
the worst pile that wrap by fire
[Applause]